are there trans people in the Bible? yeah.
does it say they're going to hell?
no, Jesus actually lifts up gender queer people as
model disciples.
really? yeah.
Matthew 1912.
there are eunuchs who were born that way,
some who are made eunuchs by others,
and some who will become eunuchs
for the sake of the kingdom of heaven.
and eunuchs are castrated men.
short answer, yes.
but being a eunuch is not the same as being trans.
trans can mean a lot of things.
but here's how this passage affirms gender queer, trans,
gender nonconforming,
and intersex people. go on.
first it says some people are born eunuchs.
Jesus affirms
there can be more than just male or female at birth.
then Jesus says some will become Unix
for the sake of the kingdom of heaven.
in other words,
some people who are assigned male at birth
will later choose a different gender identification
as part of their work of following God.
couldn't it be symbolic?
I thought this was about priests being celibate.
priest didn't have to be celibate until the 1100s.
also, a lot of Unix could
and did still have sexual relationships,
they just couldn't procreate.
weren't they also outcast? yes.
while some eunuchs had high
power jobs in the royal courts,
they also faced a lot of discrimination.
so it's notable when a Christian, Philip,
runs into an Ethiopian eunuch along the road,
and the eunuch says,
what is there to prevent me from being baptized.
Philip doesn't say,
well, you can't be a Christian
because you don't fit the gender binary.
Philip stops the chariot,
goes down to the water,
and baptizes them.
so if people don't fit the binary,
whether they're born that way
or they even choose that later in life,
they're cool with Jesus.
they're not just cool with him,
they're celebrated as models of discipleship.